we begin this morning with breaking news
overnight of a deadly fire in Hawaii at
least three people were killed and at
least 16 others were injured in a
high-rise fire in Honolulu near the
Waikiki tourist area the fire began on
the 26th floor of the 36th floor
building thick black smoke streamed out
of the high-rise for about four hours
leaving many trapped falling debris
caused the fire to spread to lower
floors residents said the scene
resembled a horror movie these women
were just screaming three or four female
voices dis screaming constant screaming
help me help me help me we noticed the
smoke coming up that's our unit cuz it
was right underneath of us and then
after that we they squeak debauch
yeah we heard some explosions look down
we saw the flame three bodies were found
in the apartment where the fire started
the building did not have a sprinkler
system it was built in 1971 before
sprinklers were required without a doubt
if there were sprinklers in this
apartment the fire would be contained to
the unit of origin over a hundred
firefighters responded to the blaze the
cause has not been determined